bien je suis très content de vous voir
si nombreuse ce matin pour cette
première table ronde qui ouvre notre
journée de réflexion alors ce matin
c'est une table ronde très intéressante
avec des intervenants de grande qualité
une table ronde sur le sujet de
l'indépendance comme nous de paix alors
cette question est très certainement
plus que jamais d'actualité et on a la
chance d'avoir à nos côtés Marco notre
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire
Madame Agnès panier renacher notre
ministre de la transition énergétique
merci d'être avec nous ce matin
Marie-Christine Marghem donc notre
l'ancienne ministre fédéral belge en
charge de l'énergie de l'environnement
et du développement durable et actuel
député et présidente de commission de la
Commission du Budget et des Finances
voilà merci d'être avec nous ce matin
[Applaudissements]
l'incontournable Christophe Grudler
député européen voilà
et à côté de moi Sébastien abis merci
d'être avec nous Sébastien est directeur
du club Demeter qui réfléchit qui porte
des réflexions sur les enjeux mondiaux
les dynamiques intersectes
interceptorielles il chercheur associés
à l'Iris spécialiste des questions
alimentaires et légalement auteurs et je
vous remercie d'être avec nous ce matin
voilà
alors cette notion d'indépendance elle a
fortement évolué ces dernières années
elle a eu tendance à s'imposer dans le
débat public au point de devenir
incontournable c'est le cœur de l'action
de notre président de la République et
des gouvernements successifs depuis 2017
et les événements et les crises qui se
sont succédés c'est ces dernières années
ont remis en cause notre modèle et nous
ont appelé à des à des réflexions
parfois revoir nos méthodes de travail
et aussi à se poser une question
fondamentale c'est de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui à l'échelle
française qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à
l'échelle européenne et surtout
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire demain pour
réduire notre dépendance et garder toute
cette notion de puissance donc ce que je
vous propose c'est de faire un premier
tour de table
assez rapide parce que cette notion à
force qu'elle s'élargissent dans les
dans les différents champs d'action
en fait elle perd de sa de sa précision
je regarde une autre ministre de
l'agriculture dans le domaine de
l'agriculture la notion d'indépendance
n'est pas la même que dans le dans le
domaine de l'énergie que dans le domaine
de l'industrie donc il y a cette
question qui se pose donc moi j'ai une
question très simple mais à la fois très
complexe c'est de savoir Monsieur le
Ministre qu'est-ce qu'on entend par
cette notion d'indépendance stratégique
bonjour à toutes et à tous d'avoir merci
d'avoir choisi ce thème on pourrait
mettre indépendance virgule nouvelle
arme de guerre aussi ce qui ferait le
pendant de c'est pour ça qu'il faut en
faire une arme de paix parce que ça peut
potentiellement devenir une arme de
guerre et heureux de retrouver Agnès et
de vous retrouver toutes et tous sur
cette tribune pour parler de ce sujet
c'est quoi l'indépendance et la
souveraineté enfin ça c'est un concept
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
d'ailleurs d'abord c'est vrai ce que tu
as dit on est dans un moment où sans
doute la crise ukrainienne la covid
alors la covid elle a montré les
interdépendances et la fragilité de nos
systèmes et en quoi le système pouvait
être un peu plus résilient que celui
qu'on avait construit qui était on
allait chercher des masques en Chine on
allait chercher
du doliprane ou l'équivalent du
paraissait témol c'était pour pas donner
de marque telle ou tel endroit on avait
on a vu les limites de l'hyper
spécialisation
c'est pas qu'on a subi cette hyper
spécialisation c'est qu'on la souhaitait
on a dit après tout on va laisser à
certains faire une partie de la
production et c'est au moment de la
crise covid qu'on s'est dit bah quand ça
ferme dans un pays
pour un motif sanitaire mais on avait
oublié que ça pouvait être pour un motif
sanitaire comme ça pourrait être pour un
motif géopolitique ou guerrier on s'est
rendu compte qu'une partie des objets
aussi simple qu'un masque et aussi
complexe que des processeurs
pouvaient manquer
l'ensemble de la chaîne et donc ça c'est
un premier élément de ce qu'à sa révélé
de notre fragilité d'interdépendance un
peu subi et d'interdépendance fragile et
puis le deuxième sujet c'est la guerre
en Ukraine
on en reparlera peut-être tout là tout à
l'heure mais
je considère que Vladimir Poutine a
construit une stratégie
d'abord de sa propre indépendance mais
infini et un objectif de démarrage qui
est un objectif de mettre les autres
sous forme de dépendance en faisant de
on en parle souvent avec Sébastien
abysse en faisant de l'alimentation une
arme
quand vous regardez les deux sujets mais
Agnès en parlera beaucoup mieux que moi
les deux sujets sur lesquels il a décidé
de faire pousser la Russie c'est
énergies agriculture et reconnaissons
qui a 25 ans on avait l'impression que
c'était quand même une tout ça c'était
plutôt des des stratégies obsolètes on
disait l'énergie le pétrole le gaz on
savait déjà quand même qu'on était vers
quelque chose qui doit un jour finir et
l'agriculture est le sentiment que le
problème était réglé et tactiquement il
a quand même mis un sacré bazar en
faisant ça
donc pour moi l'indépendance alors
d'abord l'indépendance c'est pas
l'autarcie
c'est pas le repli sur soi c'est
forcément me semble-t-il pour nous
d'abord parce que c'est de la
construction que nous avons choisie mais
globalement c'est dans l'espace européen
qu'elle peut se construire je ne vois
pas qu'on puisse construire y compris
dans ces dérèglements du monde y compris
dans le dérèglement climatique quelque
chose qui soit simplement le
la préoccupation de comment je nourris
ma propre population pour nourrir ma
propre population j'ai besoin de facteur
de production j'ai besoin d'engrais j'ai
besoin d'énergie et d'énergie pour faire
des engrais j'ai besoin d'un certain
nombre de facteurs de production que je
ne pourrais pas jamais tout à fait
fournir tout seul donc j'ai besoin de
trouver un espace dans lequel je sois
sécurisé de mon approvisionnement et
dans lequel je ne sois pas seul face à
mon approvisionnement sinon je prends un
risque me semble-t-il assez terrible
donc c'est au moins dans l'espace
européen
et deuxième élément juste pour faire
vite parce que tu m'as demandé de faire
vite je pense que la souveraineté est
l'indépendance c'est pas la solitude
c'est un peu comment politique
d'ailleurs une certaine façon
et c'est la capacité à générer des
interdépendants mais qu'on choisit et
qu'on subit pas c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
qu'on puisse choisir nos interdépendants
c'est avec qui je veux faire du commerce
vers qui je peux me retourner si j'ai un
problème et quels sont mes alliés dans
la durée qui me paraissent les plus
solide alors on est dans un monde où
rien n'est tout à fait solide mais je
reconnais que même si je suis pas
géopoliticien l'idée de cette Mia ce
point dans les mains du géant russe sans
savoir que ça pouvait dériver c'est
quand même un truc curieux parce que
dans l'histoire on sait à quel point
c'est continent là c'est
c'est pays continent si je peux dire ont
eu des stratégies qui étaient parfois
des stratégies de domination voilà
c'était juste pour donner quelques
merci beaucoup je me tourne vers Agnès
panière une hachée qui a une mission
très importante quand on parle
d'autonomie stratégique la question de
l'énergie et on a vu à quel point c'est
fondamental au-delà de tout ce qui peut
nous dépasser aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
une question qui est au cœur des
préoccupations de tous les citoyens de
France et d'Europe et donc forcément
vous agissez même question sur le plan
énergétique comment est-ce qu'on peut
concevoir cette notion d'indépendance et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait surtout pour nous
garantir déjà un approvisionnement
énergétique et au-delà de ça comment on
fait pour garantir un approvisionnement
énergétique qui répond aux enjeux de
notre époque et je pense notamment au
développement durable à transition
énergétique et bien sûr à la
décarbonation de notre de notre monde
alors déjà bonjour à toutes et à tous et
merci de m'avoir invité sur sur ce
plateau c'est un grand plaisir de
retrouver notre enfin mon
partenaire puisque moi je ne suis pas
modem mais je veux le dire ici toujours
très fiable dans les combats
je voudrais juste prendre un temps de
recul pour dire ce qui a changé de monde
point de vue et qui rend cette question
d'indépendance beaucoup plus cruciale
aujourd'hui le temps de recul c'est la
géopolitique qu'est-ce qui est en train
de se passer on a effectivement une
chute qui est quand même la plus grande
puissance mondiale sur le papier c'est à
dire le plus de population le plus de
territoires le plus de ressources et
aujourd'hui
faisant partie de plus de capacités
technologiques qui se positionne comme
une puissance et qui assume ce statut de
puissance et qui t'entraîne de de
vouloir prendre un leadership mondial
vous avez la réponse américaine donc ça
c'est et une Europe qui est confrontée à
ces deux éléments de déstabilisation
mais vous avez un troisième phénomène
qui me paraît très important
c'est la montée des briques et je trouve
très significatif ce qui s'est passé il
y a quelques semaines c'est quand le
Brésil la Russie l'Inde la Chine se met
ensemble et disent on va élargir à
d'autres pays qui sont l'Éthiopie l'Iran
tout ça n'est pas du tout
anecdotique et c'est en train de nous
mettre de nous confronter avec un une
tension détention géopolitique qui sont
en train de changer la distribution des
cartes mondiales et je pense que face à
ça l'Europe a probablement fait preuve
et d'arrogance et de naïveté
d'arrogance parce que l'idée qu'on va
organiser des chaînes
d'approvisionnement mondial en gardant
les activités qui ont le plus de valeur
ajoutée chez nous et en laissant les
ateliers du monde prendre ce qui est
polluant ce qui est ce qui n'apporte pas
beaucoup d'argent mais sur lequel on
peut faire trimer des centaines de
milliers de personnes c'est de
l'arrogance et c'est d'ailleurs assez
cynique au passage
et puis de la naïveté parce que
malheureusement la fin de l'histoire
c'est pas tout à fait ce qui est arrivé
et nous sommes plutôt dans une phase
d'accélération de l'histoire avec de
réels risques de conflits à haute
intensité et pas seulement en Ukraine
mais vraiment aux portes de l'Europe en
mer de Chine et dans d'autres endroits
ce qui se passe en Afrique doit
également nous alerter donc je pense que
ce paysage là il faut l'avoir en tête
quand on passe quand on pense
l'indépendance et la souveraineté
maintenant la difficulté de la France
quand elle parle d'indépendance c'est
cette indépendance qui est une
souveraineté ouverte en Europe c'est à
dire de pousser l'Union européenne à
être sa puissance indépendante et pas
d'être la France indépendante contre
tout le monde ici on prend le sujet de
l'énergie comment fait-on là aussi quel
est le paysage deux tiers de notre
énergie est importée du gaz et du
Pétrole deux tiers on est tous somnubilé
par l'électricité sur l'électricité on
est très bon il se trouve que l'éléphant
dans la pièce c'est le gaz et le pétrole
120 milliards d'euros de dépenses chaque
année donc c'est pas l'épaisseur du
trait et comment on change ça et ben il
faut construire une politique
effectivement d'indépendance énergétique
qui n'a jamais existé on a toujours été
dépendant énergétiquement toujours en
tout cas depuis la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale je vous parle pas du Moyen-Âge
ou une structure était plus fermées mais
on a toujours été indépendant et les
l'énergie pas chère et abondante c'est
ce qui fait de la productivité c'est ce
qui fait de la croissance donc c'est ça
qu'il faut résoudre donc comment fait-on
il faut tout reprendre à plat baisser
notre consommation d'énergie augmenter
notre capacité de production nationale
et augmenter de notre capacité de
production nationale ces pensées les
chaînes d'approvisionnement derrière
qu'il s'agisse du nucléaire où on est
relativement très indépendant si ce
n'est sur l'approvisionnement d'uranium
naturel où les énergies renouvelables où
nous pouvons devenir
indépendant mais où nous sommes très
dépendants sur tout ce qui est composant
et donc à chaque fois qu'on construit
quelque chose on dépend aujourd'hui
assez largement de la Chine et donc le
plan c'est conjugué énergie et industrie
merci beaucoup je me tourne vers
Marie-Christine Marghem alors vous avez
exercé des responsabilités au
gouvernement en Belgique vous êtes
actuellement élu à la Chambre des
Représentants même question et
particulièrement sur la sur la question
énergétique parce que je connais votre
engagement sur le sur le sujet sur les
questions notamment du nucléaire et
madame la ministre vient de nous le dire
que l'électricité c'est très
certainement l'endroit où on est le
moins dépendant
comment est-ce qu'on conçoit aujourd'hui
le l'avenir en matière énergétique
notamment sur la question du nucléaire
et comment est-ce que on arrive à se
projeter dans un dans un avenir ou un
moment où on se disait que le nucléaire
on y arrive on arrive à la fin de ce
modèle là qu'il faut renouveler
alors tout d'abord merci de votre
accueil très chaleureux dans cette
contrée que je ne connaissais pas encore
sur un sujet
très vaste et très épineux on dit si tu
veux la paix prépare la guerre et ici je
vois dans votre titre nouvelle arme de
paix c'est pratiquement le même sens
c'est une façon de dire comment
soumettre l'adversaire sans combattre
alors tout ça est très guerrier mais au
fond ça revient à ça et je relis ce que
je dis à ma collègue interlocutrice
juste avant moi qui explique les
équilibres géopolitiques
auquel nous devons faire face en 2014
quand j'entre en fonction comme ministre
de l'énergie de l'environnement et du
développement durable la Russie envahit
la Crimée et là nous savons déjà pour
ceux qui sont un peu plus perspicaces
que nous aurons des problèmes et des
tensions sur la provisionnement en gaz
par exemple et bien entendu au lieu de
prévoir au lieu de s'organiser au lieu
de déjà mettre en place les éléments
d'une souveraineté ou d'une indépendance
énergétique on serait en dehors jusqu'au
moment où le conflit Russo ukrainien se
fait jour en 2022 et voilà le problème
l'accélération vient de là l'urgence
n'est du retard je pense qu'aussi bien
en matière d'électricité en matière
d'approvisionnement énergétique qui nous
permet d'être mobile de chauffer nos
habitations comme tout ce qui est
pétrole et gaz nous devons avoir une
attention beaucoup plus grande à ce qui
se passe dans le monde
et ne pas nous mettre entre les mains
des puissances telles que la Chine pour
toutes les composantes qui nous
permettent d'avoir des panneaux solaires
de faire des éoliennes et de produire de
l'électricité par exemple avec le gaz
qui par ailleurs aimait beaucoup de CO2
l'indépendance énergétique avec le
vecteur électrique sur base du nucléaire
je me suis battu comme une lionne et je
continue à le faire pour que mon pays
comme le vôtre recouvre un minimum
d'indépendance énergétique en production
d'électricité mais pour tout ce qui
concerne les autres vecteurs d'énergie
les autres sources d'énergie qui
viennent d'ailleurs et qui sont
évidemment géolocalisés ailleurs là nous
devons avoir un minimum de capacité à
entrer en relation équilibrée avec le
reste du monde donc il faut pas se faire
d'illusion on aura encore besoin d'un
peu de gaz on aura encore besoin de
pétrole et la souveraineté c'est la
capacité à imposer un minimum de
crédibilité
aux autres pour pouvoir entrer en
relation avec eux dans cet équilibre
qu'il faut rechercher et soumettre donc
son adversaire sans combattre à cette
équilibre et donc nous sommes un petit
pays nous devons trouver des moyens de
nous développer nous ne pouvons pas avec
le territoire exigu qui est le nôtre
assuré la souveraineté alimentaire de
notre pays aucun pays d'ailleurs sauf si
mon collègue de droite me prouve le
contraire même si votre pays est très
vaste et comporte de très très grandes
contrées qui peuvent être cultivés on
cultive ce qu'on peut cultiver sous
cette latitude on exporte pas mal de
choses mais alors du coup on importe et
c'est cet équilibre là qu'il faut
rechercher y compris notre technologie
avancée peut-être exporté mais alors on
importe des choses qui nous servent et
ça c'est la paix c'est la paix dans le
monde c'est une paix bien ordonnée qui
est fondée sur la charité qui commence
soi-même et c'est ça que j'ai essayé
d'expliquer à mes collègues quand
j'étais en charge mais ils étaient
lancés à cette époque là ils voulaient
connu aussi en France malheureusement
dans une époque où on était persuadé que
la transition énergétique c'était
uniquement fondée sur leur ouvrage une
des erreurs de l'Europe c'est de penser
cela alors aujourd'hui ma recette
covidge avec qui j'ai eu l'honneur de
travailler commence à faire des
déclarations qui sont pleines de bon
sens et qui d'ailleurs se relie à son
tempérament après avoir beaucoup prêché
pour le renouvelable au lieu de dire que
c'était l'intermittent parce que c'était
ça qui fallait dire il dit maintenant
que nous n'atteindrons pas nos objectifs
en termes de lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique et nous engagements européens
en la matière si nous ne développons pas
la filière nucléaire autrement dit s'il
nous un industrions
n'industrialisant pas pardonnez-moi
l'Europe le territoire européen et
industrialisé ça veut pas dire
nécessairement faire des choses
polluantes ça veut dire créer une chaîne
vous l'avez expliqué une chaîne de
valeur européenne avec notre savoir
technologique mais qui nous permettent
justement d'exister entre les pôles
puissants et
vampirisant que sont la Chine les
États-Unis et maintenant les bricks
voilà
merci beaucoup
Christophe alors tu es vice coordinateur
de du groupe Renou au sein de la
commission industrie recherche et
énergie au Parlement européen
comme ça vient d'être dit la question de
la réindustrialisation de la France et
la réindustrie de l'Europe c'est
certainement ça l'enjeu majeur qui qui
nous attend et sur lequel je sais que
vous avez une une action très importante
au niveau du Parlement européen est-ce
que tu peux nous parler de cette
réindustrialisation et aussi le rôle
fondamental de l'innovation qui est en
fait est au cœur de des politiques
européennes avec plaisir bonjour à
toutes et à tous je suis très très
heureux de participer à cette table
ronde avec plein d'invités de qualité
autour du terme de l'indépendance et
c'est clair que c'est un plaisir devant
l'assemblée du Mouvement Démocrate de
parler d'indépendance alors que le parti
c'est constitué sur cette idée
d'indépendance
et le le le deuxième ligne nouvelle arme
de paix il faut que philosophiquement
savoir quand même que l'indépendance
c'est d'abord la guerre avant d'être la
paix parce que je reprends la parole du
MoDem quand la monnaie m'a décidé de
s'affranchir de la gauche et de la
droite pour dire on existe au centre ça
c'est pas fait avec des caresses dans le
dos de la part de ceux dont dépendait
avant et c'est le principe indépendance
à partir du moment où vous existez par
vous-même vous êtes respecté par les
autres il vous traite des gars légales
mais faut d'abord arriver à s'extirper
cette forme de dépendance c'est pour ça
que il faut il faut se bagarrer dans cet
esprit là et à la place d'indépendance
mon terme favori c'est l'autonomie
stratégique c'est je trouve que c'est le
mot alors on prend un débattre sur
ouverte derrière parce que ça c'est nos
amis les libéraux qui veulent absolument
mettre ça derrière mais l'autonomie
stratégique c'est un concept français
déjà
ce mot est apparu pour la première fois
en 1993 dans le Livre blanc de la
défense en France on a créé le concept
d'autonomie stratégique c'est un gros
mot qui veut dire quelque chose de très
simple on veut avoir son destin entre
ses mains
dépendent de soi-même et pas des autres
ça veut pas dire surfermé se replier ça
veut dire être respecté en tant que tel
définir ses partenaires et pas être des
supplétifs des uns ou des autres et donc
c'est pour revenir directement à ta
question sur le sur l'industrie c'est le
même principe effectivement dans
l'industrie mais ça vaut pour la défense
ça vaut pour l'énergie ça vaut pas
l'agriculture ça vaut pour tout se faire
respecter et effectivement c'est pas
l'auteur sinon plus on va pas subitement
se dire qu'au niveau de l'Union
européenne au niveau de la France on va
replier notre économie sur nous-mêmes
alors qu'on est dans un
marcher mondialisé on va dire c'est
global market dans un vilain anglais et
donc l'autonomie stratégique
c'est d'abord faire chez soi qu'on peut
mais c'est aussi aller chercher des
partenaires à l'extérieur et puis
beaucoup de partenaires parce que si je
prends l'exemple des Allemands qui
dépendaient à 80 % du gaz russe quand il
y a plus de gaz russe et ben voilà c'est
comme un épicier qui a un client qui
fait 80% de son chiffre d'affaires le
jour où le client ne pleure il est mort
donc c'est le même principe on peut
parfaitement avoir
10 15 20 canaux de d'approvisionnement
différents on n'est pas en danger on
reste en autonomie stratégique donc on
développe les textes au niveau du
Parlement européen sur ces questions
d'industrie
lié souvent l'énergie d'ailleurs on
travaille beaucoup avec Agnès sur ces
sur ces questions là
alors les plus récents parce que on peut
pas être trop non plus c'est alors le
net 0 industrie Act
bon c'est les technologies propres
européennes on va dire on veut
relocaliser on veut développer au nom de
l'innovation les technologies de demain
alors qu'ils peuvent être malgristine
des technologies nucléaires aussi
puisqu'on travaille sur le nucléaire de
3e et 4e génération sur le SMS
voilà donc on sait qu'on s'entretient
pour pousser un peu l'idée et que le
club nucléaire porté par Agnès et aussi
quelque chose d'assez dynamique on
essaye d'avoir de développer nos
technologies propres en résistance à
l'IRA américain donc
le process de lutte contre l'inflation
aux États-Unis où il y a des milliards
sur la table pour éventuellement
débaucher nos entreprises européennes
pour qu'elles aillent produire là-bas
donc
cette technologie propre c'est pour
pousser la création en Europe de techno
je prendrai un seul exemple je reprends
encore le nucléaire puisque puisque on y
est bon
on a des supers boîtes en France qui
nous font du SMR le SMR c'est des
réacteurs de petites puissances de 40
mégawatts installés jusqu'à 500 600 dans
certains cas le New Art français il fait
340 mégawatts et donc
il y a un vrai potentiel chez nous
là-dessus il y a un vrai porté sur la
quatrième génération avec naréa avec des
spin-offs du CEA qui sont extrêmement
pertinents donc on a ce qu'il faut en
techno
sauf que comme on a des dogmatiques
anti-nucléaires alors dogmaticotinières
crainte au niveau de la compétitivité
parce qu'il pense que la France va de
l'énergie moins cher pour faire tourner
son industrie par rapport aux autres
pays tout ça on essaie de nous bloquer
au niveau techno et qu'est-ce qui va se
passer dans 10 ans
bien merci
maintenant que les constats sont faits
que les premières actions ont pu être un
peu développées je me tourne vers vous
Sébastien bis avec votre regard de de
spécialistes de chercheurs est-ce que
vous pensez que la France que l'Europe
est aujourd'hui armé pour répondre à ces
défis
je vais être beaucoup plus dans les
constats que dans les actions puisque
j'ai cru comprendre que c'était
davantage mon rôle que les autres
personnes sur cette table ronde merci de
votre invitation j'ai entendu beaucoup
de choses
qui qui résonnent fortement sur laquelle
je reviendrai pas mais je me dis que
peut-être un jour il faudrait que je
prenne la carte de ce parti vu les
affinités de penser
ce que ce que je voudrais
dire c'est peut-être trois grandes
séries de considérations la première
c'est les constats qu'on doit faire qui
sont pas des constats pour regarder dans
le rétroviseur mais peut-être pour pour
se projeter dans l'avenir le premier
c'est que la sécurité n'est jamais
acquise et on a peut-être eu tort en
Europe en France de penser que en termes
de santé en termes de combat physique en
termes de risque sanitaire en termes de
d'approvisionnement dont nous avons tout
le temps besoin nous étions sortis de
l'inconfort et nous avantions
allègrement dans un siècle où il y
aurait pas de souci on a même expliqué
une partie de la planète qu'elle devait
évidemment espérer la même chose sans
forcément lui donner les moyens
d'acquérir ces mêmes sécurités je crois
qu'il faut rappeler ça parce que la
sécurité qui est jamais acquise
ça veut dire qu'il faut l'entretenir ça
avait coût des questions de formation
c'est les questions de de priorité on
les appelle comme on veut on classe des
secteurs dans l'autonomie stratégique on
est dans des dépendances quand on peut
des interdépendants qu'on doit
cultiver choisir etc mais ça veut dire
vraiment être en capacité plus que
jamais dans le monde contemporain pour
l'Europe et pour la France de distinguer
l'essentiel du superflu c'est à dire que
les sécurités indispensables et sécurité
humaine indispensables qui traversent
les saisons les années les émotions on a
besoin
d'être robuste d'avoir du capacitaire et
donc si on n'a pas les moyens de tout
faire je pense que l'Europe et la France
doivent aussi accepter en étant déjà un
quart de siècle l'entrée dans ce 21ème
en capacité de faire des choix et
peut-être de plus vouloir tout faire
mais de se dire où est l'essentiel et
qu'est-ce qui est plus superflu à la
fois pour la vie des gens et leur
sécurité mais également ce que nous ne
sommes plus en capacité de faire soit
parce que le match est perdu soit parce
que ça ne correspond pas à ce qu'on
souhaite faire par rapport à ces enjeux
européens et de souveraineté le deuxième
constat c'est que comme le libéralisme
économique n'entraîne pas la démocratie
ça veut dire que l'Europe en effet sort
d'une séquence durant laquelle elle a
cru pouvoir exporter un certain nombre
de valeurs et penser que une partie du
monde voir tout le monde allait vouloir
ressembler à nos systèmes et là aussi on
a ni vu une traduction dans certaines
régions du monde de cette dynamique et
je ne suis pas certain qu'on la voit
davantage dans les prochaines années
la troisième considération c'est
l'interdépendance économique
à part peut-être en Europe mais je
reviendrai sur l'Europe après mais
l'interdépendance économique n'entraîne
pas mécaniquement la paix
n'en déplaise cette théorie qui a
suscité des des attentes on voit qu'un
certain nombre de pays ont des liens
économiques forts mais sont en même
temps en rivalité sur d'autres secteurs
et donc on voit bien qu'un certain
nombre d'acteurs sur la planète
aujourd'hui peuvent être à la fois en
coopération et en même temps en
compétition le lendemain sur un autre
registre puisque de toute façon la
logique de puissance aujourd'hui c'est
de défendre ses intérêts pas défendre
des valeurs et du collectif ça n'existe
pas les amitiés en relation
internationales vous le savez et donc ça
veut dire on défend ses intérêts et on a
une politique étrangère multi alignée
multidirectionnel parfois
contradictoires selon notre prisme de
représentation du monde mais qui n'est
pas forcément contradictoire aux yeux de
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs donc une
fois qu'on a dit tout ça
ça veut dire que la naïveté des
herbivores ne convertit jamais les
carnivores véganisme stratégiques
et monsieur le ministre c'est de quoi je
parle
et donc je pense et je vous prie de me
pardonner l'expression que j'utilise
depuis une année mais il faut qu'on
prenne conscience en Europe et en France
que nous sortons des 30 glandeuse
à vous entendre sur les différents
sujets et quand je dis ça je pense pas
qu'on a arrêté de faire des choses en
Europe on a quand même demandé depuis 30
ans une partie de la planète de bosser
pour nous
et on se plaint aujourd'hui que les
salaires les niveaux de vie les
puissances économiques les innovations
de certains pays nous concurrence on a
délocalisé nos déchets et donc on a des
carbonées mobiles et tout ça est aussi
une une critique que une partie du monde
nous formule aujourd'hui quand on leur
dit qu'on est en avance sur nos bilans
de décarbonation
donc sa questionne donc la fin des 30
glandeuses c'est à la fois faire des
choix reconsidérer qu'il y a des
secteurs de sécurité première sur
lesquelles il faut reprendre du capacité
donc produire des choses qui se touchent
parfois en Europe et pas que des idées
et pas que des idées
et donc
en même temps et je viens sur le terrain
européen en même temps ne pas vouloir
renforcement ressembler assez carnivore
tyrannosaure qui sont de retour sur la
planète moi je suis très frappé par le
débat sur les bricks par exemple ce
concept marketing financier en 20 ans
est devenu un bloc géopolitique
totalement contradictoire en interne il
faut pas non plus se tromper ces pays se
ressemblent pas veulent pas forcément
travailler sur tous les sujets ensemble
mais on a entendu ces dernières semaines
c'est génial ils vont construire une
monnaie commune des alliances
sectorielles ils vont faire une banque
de développement
il y a quand même un espace en Europe
depuis plus de 50 ans qui a créé un peu
tout ça qui fonctionne plutôt pas mal
qui s'appelle l'Union européenne et de
temps en temps avant de dire que les
briques sont très unis très fort comme
bloc on peut peut-être se rendre compte
que le modèle le plus intégré et
potentiellement le plus fort de la
planète qui plus est avec des valeurs et
c'est là la nuance ça s'appelle l'Union
européenne et donc ça il faut
réhabiliter aussi ce que l'Union
européenne me semble-t-il et avec du
coup au niveau des briques une petite
vigilance que je me permets de glisser
certes Russie Chine ça va sans dire mais
ne succombo pas
à une espèce d'indomania dans les
prochaines années
et n'oublions pas que Lula 3 n'est pas
forcément notre meilleur ami
je me permets de le dire il suffit de
regarder sur certains sujets à quel
point c'est c'est nuances doivent être
en tout cas tenus et je dirais la même
chose sur la question du lien
transatlantique qui est un peu réveillé
avec la guerre en Ukraine
je crois pas que le temps est en mort
cérébrale militaire par contre elle est
en mort cérébrale économique le
partenariat économique industriel le
scientifique transatlantique va mal et
donc on doit aussi je crois sans
naïveter aucune regardez la relation
avec les États-Unis en Europe et en
France comme une relation qui est
évidemment à cultivée mais sans
forcément perdre de vue que America
First ça veut dire beaucoup de choses
quel que soit la couleur des
gouvernements à la Maison Blanche donc
l'Europe a beaucoup d'atouts beaucoup de
force moi je crois qu'il y avait un
besoin de changer un peu le narratif
défendent beaucoup plus nos intérêts
tout en défendant nos valeurs
je disais ministre à quel point sur un
certain nombre de sujets comme l'Ukraine
nous devons essayer de cultiver
l'impossible mais c'est ça la force de
l'Europe et donc avec l'Ukraine
solidarité mais exigence parce que si on
n'est pas dans cette équilibre on voit
ce que ça provoque très vite dans
certaines sociétés européennes et donc
je voudrais finir sur trois trois points
vous avez parlé à juste titre
globalement market attention à ce que
l'Europe ne soit pas dans une stratégie
globale lol c'est à dire on pense monde
mais en fait on est tout seul on se
périphérie
on va expliquer aux autres ce qu'il faut
faire et en même temps ils ont pas
forcément envie de le faire et ils ont
des attentes sur certains secteurs et on
et nous on n'est pas en capacité de les
satisfaire alors que parfois on pourrait
comme sur les sujets agricoles et
alimentaires cultivés avec une partie du
monde des liens forts donc attention à
cela la deuxième chose je crois c'est
de savoir
beaucoup réfléchi à ce que j'ai appelé
les sherpas de la réussite pour ce
siècle moi je crois qu'il y a trois C
qui faut systématiquement marteler c'est
compliqué par les temps qui courent mais
le temps long j'ai cru comprendre que
c'était aussi l'ADN de votre mouvement
politique
et donc de la constance dans les choix
faits et dans les investissements de la
cohérence c'est-à-dire que si on parle
de réindustrialiser l'Europe il faut
peut-être déjà ne pas désagrécoliser
l'Europe puisque la première industrie
européenne c'est l'agroalimentaire c'est
vraiment en Europe c'est vrai en France
si on veut de l'autonomie énergétique
bah peut-être se rendre compte
qu'aujourd'hui 20% de l'énergie
renouvelable française provient des
mondes agricoles et donc l'agriculture
apporte beaucoup de solutions je le dis
parce que on a longtemps expliqué que
c'était un secteur du passé ça n'a
jamais été aussi central dans les
équations stratégiques contemporaines ça
veut dire cohérence on veut rien
industrialiser ça veut dire expliquer
aux gens de travailler dans l'industrie
c'est bien leur donner la capacité d'y
aller ça servira à rien de reconstruire
des usines si personne ne veut
travailler dans les industries donc il
faut réhabiliter tout ça et du coup j'en
viens un troisième point c'est qu'il va
falloir renforcer énormément le
l'éducationnel
il y a de la greenflation
si on est vertueux sur les transitions
écologiques en Europe il faut expliquer
que ça coûte cher la sortie du pétrole
va coûter très cher très cher
l'inflation alimentaire est une
excellente nouvelle parce que
l'alimentation est vitale et je crois
fortement qu'il faut arrêter
d'expliquer que l'alimentation et la
variable d'ajustement et donc mettez de
l'argent dans vos microbiote et pas sur
une épargne d'assurance vie à la banque
soyons très clair aussi sur la santé sur
la santé de vos territoires votre santé
individuel de la planète l'alimentation
permet de faire des choses et donc ça
veut dire la question de l'éducation
aussi dès le plus jeune âge pas que pour
les les adultes et ce rapport
aujourd'hui à cette économie de guerre
ou d'autonomie stratégique et dès le
plus jeune âge je sais que vous êtes
sensible à cette question du temps long
et de l'éducation
je crois qu'on fait encore l'école en
2023 comme on faisait l'école au siècle
dernier
et je ne sais pas je m'interroge j'ai
deux filles je ne sais pas si on est en
train de leur apprendre les savoirs
indispensables pour les sécurités
puisqu'on a expliqué qu'un certain
nombre de métiers manuels n'avaient plus
de sens les lycées professionnels
c'était moins bien les lycées agricoles
j'en parle même pas puisque il y a eu
une époque monsieur le ministre où quand
on avait un bac agricole on appelait ça
un bac déprime
c'est dire à quel point c'était
symbolique donc nous avons besoin
peut-être de revoir à quel point sur un
certain nombre de d'apprentissage
le manuel le productif ce qu'il faut
pouvoir savoir faire pour sûr dans sa
vie est importante moi j'ai 42 ans il y
a plein de choses que je ne sais pas
faire du tout et donc je suis préoccupé
sur les savoirs indispensables du 21e
siècle avec une dernière chose qui me
semble indispensable c'est qu'on perde
pas de vue l'importance du
contradictoire c'est-à-dire que
puisqu'on est en Europe et en France
cultiver le contradictoire ça veut dire
que sur un certain nombre de sujets
quel qu'il soit
s'écouter essayer de comprendre pourquoi
les uns et les autres ne pensent pas la
même chose et être dans une trajectoire
s'unir pour changer
on perd un temps fou depuis 20 ans à
opposer public privé entreprises ONG
si on veut transiter sur tous les défis
qui vont nous permettre de sortir des 30
glandeuses pour rentrer dans quelque
chose des un peu des 30 audacieuses
qu'on retrouve du peds et qu'on explique
aux jeunes de 20 ans que en 2050 ils
vont ni mourir de chaud ni moins bien
vivre que leurs parents parce que sinon
il faut passer étonner qui reste sous la
couette le dimanche matin je veux dire
et encore
donc je pense que voilà l'éducation mais
l'éducation avec en même temps le retour
aux évidences et à quelques savoirs
indispensables et encore une fois
s'unir pour changer parce que en restant
divisé un peu trop longtemps européen
France
public privé et courant de pensée
parfois sur les grands sujets on risque
de disparaître durablement et évidemment
c'est pas la trajectoire que nous
souhaitons pour pour l'Europe et la
France
bien merci merci beaucoup
alors cette notion de l'autonomie
stratégique elle elle vient notamment de
notre de la notion politique de défense
et on voulait pas mettre de côté ce
sujet là donc ce que je vous propose
c'est une petite vidéo de ça de Sabine
qu'il a notre député de la cinquième
circonscription de l'Indre-et-Loire qui
qui va revenir un peu sur sur ce sujet
bonjour à toutes et tous notre
université de rentrée et de Guidel
moment de réflexion et d'échanges nous
avons beaucoup de défis à relever
actuellement particulièrement dans un
monde où les menaces sont devenus
hybrides et protéines quand je parle de
menace je parle de défense nationale de
sécurité nationale mais également de
défense européen parce que les deux
premières passent par cet échelon là et
ces derniers temps nous avons fait des
grands progrès une certaine manière la
guerre en Ukraine a été un coup de
semence un réveil comme le dit notre
chef d'état-major nous devons regarder
le monde tel qu'il est et pas tel que
nous souhaitons qu'il soit et ça ça
implique aujourd'hui de se préoccuper de
la défense européenne nous sommes pas
devant rien nous avons déjà commencé
nous avons de la coopération structure
et permanente nous avons la politique
européenne de défense de sécurité mais
nous avons fait aussi un saut qualitatif
ça un peu avant cette guerre en Ukraine
avec le lancement de la boussole
stratégique présentée sous présidence
française du conseil pour la première
fois les 27 États membres se sont mis
autour d'une table pour identifier
ensemble quels sont ces menaces quels
sont les nouveaux domaines de
conflictualité comme le spatial comme le
numérique et essayer de trouver des
réponses actuellement il y a 80 actions
concrètes pour les années à venir nous
allons mettre en place entre autres une
force d'intervention rapide il y a aussi
pour la première fois un budget dédié à
la défense dans le budget de l'Union
européenne le Fonds européen de défense
doté de 8 milliards d'euros donc nous
réagissons nous réagissons pour faire en
sorte à ce que certains qui disent
l'Union européenne est un herbivore dans
un monde caniveau assume aussi une forme
de puissance donc plusieurs programmes
en route
plusieurs actions route mais tout ça
demande aussi une volonté politique
demande aussi la société derrière nous
pour renforcer le lien armée nation et
le lien France Europe
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc une vidéo assez complète sur
sur la sur le sujet de défense je me
retourne vers notre notre ministre de
l'Agriculture alors on voit un monde où
on a une population de plus en plus
nombreuse un monde qui a de plus en plus
fin une un monde qui rentre de plus en
plus dans la consommation de masse avec
on parlait des briques tout à l'heure
qui rentre dans cette consommation de
masse moi la question que je me pose
c'est de savoir quel est le rôle de
l'Europe sur les questions de politique
de solidarité alimentaire et quand on
parle d'indépendance comment est-ce
qu'on reçoit la notion de solidarité
parce que indépendance on l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises reprises c'est pas un
repli sur soi on a certainement aussi ce
devoir de solidarité et donc voilà ma
voilà ma question
merci beaucoup je voulais revenir sur
deux ou trois points qui ont été dit
avant de répondre à la question
d'abord je crois acheter à ce qui a dit
Sébastien avis sur la question de la
hiérarchie des valeurs
ce qui doit amener d'ailleurs une
réflexion sur les affaires sonantes et
trébulences je suis très frappé du débat
ce qu'on a sur l'inflation y compris
alimentaire
au fond nous explique quand même que
finalement c'est là-dessus qu'on doit
faire pression parce que dans la
hiérarchie des valeurs intuitivement si
on dit que c'est là dessus qu'on doit
faire pression ça veut dire que dans la
hiérarchie des valeurs on considère que
c'est plutôt plus bas qu'autre chose
personne ne dit qu'il faut faire baisser
ces produits là
or tout le monde en a et ça pèse lourd
dans le budget de nos concitoyens donc
on a besoin d'inverser quelque chose en
se disant si certains sujets
d'indépendance de souveraineté et un
sujet vital il faut qu'on y mette le
prix parce que c'est un coup
l'indépendance et c'est ce que vous avez
dit je pense que c'est un élément
extrêmement important de le penser comme
ça deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est
je rejoins ce qui a été dit sur la
question de l'école et de l'éducation
moi je me souviens d'un monde alors je
suis un peu plus âgé que mon voisin mais
où on nous expliquait quand même
que il y avait trois économies
l'économie primaire l'économie
secondaire et l'économie de tertiaire
que l'économie primaire était en train
de disparaître dans ces deux volets qui
étaient l'agriculture et la pêche
que l'économie secondaire allait fournie
par les pays voisins lointains plutôt
voisins d'ailleurs la Chine l'Inde
l'Afrique etc et que nous allons vivre
heureux dans le monde de l'économie de
tertiaire celle du service de la haute
technologie et du tourisme
un peu amour et au fraîche on va dire ça
comme ça c'est ma voisine qui me le
souffle
sauf qu'en fait ça ça marche pas en fait
et ce qui est assez fascinant dans le
moment qu'on traverse c'est que ce que
vous avez appelé les 30 millions d'euros
c'est qu'on s'est quand même pendant 30
ans 40 ans 50 ans versé de cette
illusion là et on a redécouvert que
quand même on avait besoin de pouvoir se
déplacer se chauffer
produire se nourrir et que tout ça
c'était quand même des sujets assez de
base c'est qui relevait plutôt des
économie primaire économie tertiaires et
ça introduit d'ailleurs dans
l'inconscient collectif l'idée que ces
métiers là étaient des métiers du passé
et pas des métiers d'avenir ce qui
explique une grande partie de la crise
qu'on a
des vocations des qu'on dit je veux
travailler dans l'industrie c'est une
espèce de truc la France ayant été un
peu championne du monde de la du
dénigrement de l'industrie pour le coup
plus que d'autres pays voisins même
peut-être les Belges en tout cas
certainement les Allemands sur ce voilà
je pense qu'on a réussi un peu à verser
ce qu'on a fait sur la question
l'apprentissage je pense que ce qu'on a
fait depuis 6 ou 7 ans le président de
la République est arrivé je pense qu'on
a réussi à réinverser l'idée que au fond
il fallait d'abord pouvoir des emplois
et dès qu'on pouvait s'épanouir dans
d'autres voies que qui voit qui étaient
dévoluent troisième chose quatrième
chose et ça m'amènera au sujet c'est
les dinosaures et les
diplodocus et les tyrannosaures
les choses qu'on échange de temps en
temps avec Sébastien avis
d'abord faut regarder comment les autres
font les accords internationaux et nous
les partenariats je suis toujours très
fasciné de voir comment font les
Australiens les Néo-Zélandais on dit
souvent on a un accord très déséquilibré
parce que
ils nous vendent du mouton non en fait
ils ne vendent pas nous moutons il se
garantissent du fait qu'un jour si les
chinois ne leur vendent leur achètent
plus de mouton ils ont un territoire sur
lequel allez c'est à dire que il pense
les accords internationaux n'ont pas
comme des accords commerciaux mais comme
des accords géopolitiques ou de
protection géopolitique et je trouve que
l'Europe parce que c'est plutôt une
négociation européenne elle pense à
corps économique alors je t'échange des
avions des voitures contre de
l'agroalimentaire ça a été ça enfin pas
se raconter l'histoire
elle pense pas le et si on fait défaut
et quand vous regardez parfois
d'ailleurs la stratégie chinoise
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
nous sommes très exportateurs de de port
vis-à-vis de la Chine mais nous sommes
quasiment les seuls en relation avec la
Chine le président de la république
ayant ouvert ses marchés
mais nous sommes désormais plus en
situation de dépendance de la Chine par
cet accord
en situation d'interdépendance si un
jour un matin il décide de fermer comme
au néo-zélandais fermerait on sera en
situation de difficulté donc on a besoin
de diversifier dans les accords
internationaux les choses et pour
répondre à la question évoquée
le dérèglement climatique il devrait
pousser alors c'est pas alors c'est pas
si c'est une réflexion diplodocus mais
le dérèglement climatique il devrait
pousser à la coopération quand vous
regardez la capacité de production de
biomasse dans le monde ce que DJ qui
c'est qu'en gros il y a que un ou deux
espaces qui vont pouvoir produire plus
de biomasse sous contrainte climatique
c'est la Russie c'est autour de
l'article
parce que vont se libérer des terres et
des capacités de production qu'on va
perdre plutôt au sud de cet art là donc
on va avoir en plus un pays et un empire
qui va être en capacité de produire plus
quand nous produireions bien moins et
donc on a une responsabilité c'est de
celle de 1 au niveau européen de quand
même de s'assurer qu'on se nourrit je
rappelle que cette année l'Espagne va
doubler je parle sous votre œil ça
demande en céréales
probablement ukrainienne j'espère que
ukrainienne
et j'en suis pas certain vous voyez ce
que je veux dire qu'on va être dans un
moment où ceux qui nous font la guerre
sont ceux qui nous nourrissent aussi
il faut d'abord qu'on s'assure de ça et
ça nécessite je le dis quand même de
réinterroger le Green Deal dans son
fondement non pas de transition parce
que ça c'est juste mais dans son
fondement décroissant c'est à dire que
une partie du Green dead s'est bâtie sur
l'idée qu'il fallait qu'on produise
moins en Europe or le dérèglement
climatique va le faire tout seul donc on
essaie de garantir de produire autant
sur des règlements climatique et sous
contrainte climatique et sous votre
contrainte ça n'empêche pas de ne pas en
rabattre sur le reste mais la
philosophie à l'oeuvre doit être plutôt
celle-là qu'une autre philosophie il me
semble ça c'est un élément important
deuxième élément il faut battre en
brèche un peu
c'est ce que font un peu la nationalisme
ou les populistes là c'est plutôt sur le
frange droite mais ils sont assez vite
rejoints sur la frange gauche d'ailleurs
c'est le localisme et chevelu c'est
on va tout résoudre par le localisme
alors j'avais un débat avec un expert un
jour c'est à tour il disait tant heureux
du localisme et inexpliquait du
Moyen-Âge il y a jamais eu autant de
famine
qu'autant du Moyen-Âge parce que moi mon
village s'appelle marchenard si je sais
nourrir que ma population de marche
noire le jour où j'ai un pet et le
voisin dit bah moi j'ai fait pareil donc
j'ai rien à te donner bah ça finit mal
donc on a besoin d'échanger enfin je
veux dire c'est pas un gros mot
d'échanger sur et en particulier sur les
sujets agricoles et la particularité ont
des règlements climatique donc on a
besoin de construire avec les pays tirés
j'en finis parce que l'indépendance
c'est pas qu'une indépendance
alimentaire c'est pas qu'une
indépendance industrielle c'est une
indépendance géostratégique des
frontières
il importe pour moi
de savoir qui nourrit la rive-sud de la
Méditerranée voilà je crois que c'est
important
par exemple cette année l'essentiel est
approvisionné par Monsieur Poutine si il
décide de fermer
c'est printemps arabe et XXL
parce que
mais si c'est pas prise mais quantité
vous retiendrez rien des flux
migratoires ça n'existe pas quand vous
avez la mort aux trousses et que vous
avez faim prenez tous les bateaux de la
terre c'est pas vrai tout ce qui raconte
le reste raconte des bêtises et donc on
a besoin de construire des partenariats
d'interdépendance parce que ces pays-là
ne pourront pas je crois pas que
l'Égypte je parle vers me retournant
vers mon voisin je ne suis je crois que
définitivement l'Égypte contenue de sa
population et de la géographie et de sa
météorologie ne sera jamais capable de
nourrir son propre peuple toute seule
mais il vaut mieux qu'on participe
de la chaîne de solidarité qui fait
qu'il soit pas seul face à Poutine seul
face à la Chine mais que nous soyons
dans le jeu d'acteur
ceux qui fassions ensemble de les
nourrir et donc
l'autonomie stratégique pour reprendre
le terme cher à Christophe c'est une
administratégique française dans
l'Europe européenne entre elles pour ne
pas être dans la situation énergétique
dans laquelle nous nous pourrions nous
retrouver d'un point de vue alimentaire
parce que c'est le même chemin qu'on
heureusement l'énergie est passée devant
si je peux dire peut-être que ça va
avoir éveillé malheureusement pour Agnès
mais peut-être que ça va réveiller les
consciences et deux il faut se
préoccuper de qui va nourrir ce monde
pas seulement parce qu'on passe de 7 8 9
10 milliards mais que la géographie des
échanges alimentaires et une géographie
impitoyable en ce moment et on n'a pas
encore vécu une année qui viendra je le
dis c'est pas pour faire dans
catastrophe je partage avec François
l'idée que on fait pas avancer le monde
ce que je disais hier en plaisantant au
Conseil national en disant on va tous
mourir d'abord parce que c'est vrai
2 parce qu'on n'est pas pressé
et encore c'est pas sûr
parce que il y a jamais comme dit en
fait on sait pas et donc
il faut pas nourrir le 4 faces il peut y
avoir une année où le continent
nord-américain l'Australie et l'Europe
est un problème de gel de sécheresse un
mauvais alnino qui a vraiment mal tourné
bon dans ce moment là j'aimerais bien
qu'on soit pas dans une situation comme
ça dans laquelle on s'est trouvé de mais
comment va nourrir tout ce bon monde et
ça pose la question sans doute
des stocks stratégiques enfin de quelque
chose autour de ça qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on a quelque part un endroit où on
peut se retourner si un problème est un
pet pardon d'expression
alors mais le ministre de l'Agriculture
nous dit que l'échange est essentiel il
faut échanger et en matière d'énergie on
échange on échange sur un marché
particulier en Europe qui aujourd'hui
parfois remis en question
moi la question que je voulais vous
poser c'est comment est-ce qu'on doit le
faire évoluer comment est-ce qu'on le
fait évoluer et aussi quels sont
aujourd'hui les enjeux de solidarité en
matière énergétique parce qu'on exporte
de l'énergie on en importe on en exporte
de nouveau depuis depuis peu donc cette
question elle est aussi fondamentale
parce que les liens de dépendance et
d'indépendance en matière énergétique
sont tout aussi primordiaux que que pour
l'agriculture alors je vais faire comme
marque je vais réagir sur quelques
éléments et répondent ensuite à la
question je voudrais revenir sur le
sujet de valeur qui a été abordé tout à
l'heure
je crois qu'il faut d'abord être
conscient que les valeurs portées par
l'Europe les valeurs démocratiques
ne crée plus le désir dans beaucoup de
zones géographiques du monde et donc ça
doit nous amener à réfléchir nos
stratégies d'influence de soft power
comme on dit parce que ça fait partie
des sujets sur lequel il me semble que
nous faisons preuve de naïveté la
démocratie ne fait pas briller les yeux
d'une grande partie de la population
mondiale et et et ça c'est un sujet qui
qui nous met en situation de difficulté
il y a du mépris à certains moments à
l'égard de décision que nous prenons
d'un point de vue sociétal en Europe qui
ne sont pas comprises et moi je pense
que nous devons porter nos valeurs
évidemment j'ai aucun doute sur ça mais
il faut se positionner de manière
différente en soft power le deuxième
sujet c'est sur la défense et je rejoins
le propos sur la cohérence
sur la défense on a des producteurs en
Europe partout on en a en Belgique on en
a en France on en a en Allemagne on en a
en Italie et à la fin les Européens
achètent DF 15 moi je comprends pas
et je pense que sur ce sujet là nous
avons une responsabilité il se trouve
que nous avons des élections européennes
qui arrivent de porter un propos fort
sur la cohérence stratégique et la
souveraineté c'est valable pour
l'industrie c'est valable pour l'énergie
mais c'est particulièrement vrai pour la
défense dans un contexte où là aussi
nous devons encore être clair des
conflits de haute intensité pour dire
très
concrètement la guerre c'est un sujet
qui revient sur l'agenda
européen et ça doit être apporté comme
tel alors c'est vrai qu'on a des
générations qui n'ont pas connu ça ou
qui l'ont connu lointainement mais on
doit le prendre et ça doit être un sujet
majeur de notre agenda stratégique
la troisième chose c'est sur la
transition énergétique oui la transition
énergétique va être coûteuse il faut pas
mentir aux gens elle va être coûteuse
mais c'est pas parce qu'elle va être
coûteuse qu'il faut pas non plus saisir
les opportunités qu'elle ouvre et dans
la mesure où elle redistribue des cartes
à nous deux attraper les meilleures
cartes d'où le plan du président de la
République l'écologie à la française
c'est pas eu une écologie dans lequel on
est dans le déni sur les difficultés
c'est une écologie dans lequel on dit je
dois prendre ce qui est ce que m'offre
de meilleures cette transition
énergétique et je dois la conduire de
cette manière c'est à dire recréer des
filières industrielles et assumer de le
faire et chercher les filières sur
lesquelles on est les meilleurs il se
trouve que le nucléaire on est parmi les
meilleurs au monde il y a pas de doute
donc c'est une solution sans regret
regardez également comment on construit
un trajet pour les plus précaires et
pour les personnes vulnérables quand on
crée l'emploi c'est une réponse dans la
transition énergétique il y a des enjeux
d'aménagement du territoire il y a des
enjeux vous le disiez aussi sur l'emploi
de réappropriation d'un certain nombre
d'emplois je rappelle que un soudeur
dans le nucléaire c'est rémunéré autour
de 4500 euros ce qui est pas tout à fait
le SMIC voilà et que ça aussi on doit
l'embarquer dans nos politiques et dans
notre position maintenant sur l'énergie
et comment on construit un marché
européen je vais d'abord dire une chose
c'est qu'il va falloir dans les mois qui
viennent et dans un contexte aussi de
d'élection européenne lutter contre
toutes les caricatures qui tournent
autour du marché s'il suffisait d'un
texte de loi pour baisser le prix
d'électricité vous imaginez bien qu'on
l'aurait pris depuis longtemps
les Européens ne sont pas fous les
gouvernements européens ne sont pas fous
non plus
sortir du marché de l'électricité ça
n'existe pas d'ailleurs les Britanniques
qui ont fait le brexit ne sont pas
sortis du marché de l'électricité
européen pourquoi parce qu'en fait ce
qu'on appelle le marché d'électricité
européen c'est ce système qui fait que
450 millions même 500 millions
maintenant 500 millions de citoyens
puisque nous avons connecté les
Ukrainiens 500 millions de citoyens à
tout moment bénéficient d'une
électricité quelle que soit les tensions
sur notre système électrique et ce qui
s'est passé en 2022 c'est une grande
victoire puisque nous avons traversé une
des pires crises énergétiques en termes
de sécurité d'approvisionnement depuis
70 ans
et que malgré tout à aucun moment nous
avons été confrontés à une situation
d'impasse entre l'offre et la demande au
moment où les Français n'étaient plus en
capacité de produire parce que l'année
dernière il y a eu quand même deux
sujets il y a évidemment le sujet de
l'insuffisance d'accès au gaz russe or
le gaz nous permettait de produire de
l'électricité et en particulier
chez notre voisin allemand mais pas que
là mais on a eu aussi une insuffisance
de production d'énergie nucléaire en
France qui met tout le système
énergétique européen
en danger et qui est à sa responsabilité
dans l'augmentation des prix et moi j'en
tire plusieurs conclusions de ça hein
il faut collectivement qu'on produise
plus 2 on peut il faut qu'on sorte de ce
cette situation où
certains de nos voisins disent j'aime
pas l'électricité nucléaire sauf quand
je l'importe
pardon
je
il m'est arrivé d'être un peu taquin
avec mes homologues européens et de dire
mais pas de problème dans ce cas là on
arrête l'interconnexion
parce que depuis que la France est
structurellement
re-exportateur d'énergie nucléaire
massivement vous savez quoi le prix il a
baissé
donc ça c'est un prix et le fait que la
France soit support d'une d'une sécurité
d'approvisionnement européenne ça a un
prix que collectivement on doit assumer
en européen et je pense que c'est aussi
un des points qu'on doit porter au
niveau européen et la troisième chose
c'est effectivement de sortir d'une
vision ou et c'est ce qui bloque
aujourd'hui la conversation et je pense
que tu as la même approche parce qu'on
échange beaucoup avec Christophe et
c'est un de mes tireurs couchés au
Parlement européen et heureusement qu'il
est là sur pas mal de textes
mais
il faut aussi que en européen on arrête
de regarder la redistribution des parts
de marché ou la perte de compétitivité
de la Belgique par rapport à la France
de la France par rapport à l'Espagne ne
l'Espagne par rapport à l'Italie de
l'Italie par rapport à l'Allemagne parce
que en réalité nos économies sont
tellement liées que si un des gros
porteurs
cool tout le monde coulera avec et qu'il
faut regarder encore une fois la
géopolitique c'est-à-dire il faut
prendre de la hauteur où sont les la
concurrence elle est aux États-Unis elle
est en Chine elle est dans les pays
low cost comme on dit d'Asie du Sud-Est
et on voit bien dans cette structuration
je partage complètement c'est à dire les
briques c'est un bricolage mais c'est en
même temps une volonté de puissance
affirmée contre l'Occident et c'est
comme ça qui je pense il faut il faut
l'entendre avec la volonté de reprendre
les parts de marché donc le danger il
est à l'extérieur il est pas à
l'intérieur et donc il faut éviter une
stratégie ou chacun étant tellement
soucieux de sa propre compétitivité qui
est-elle le Scorpion va tuer l'autre et
il va se tuer en même temps
et c'est ça qu'on est en train de vivre
sur les discussions que nous avons
aujourd'hui au niveau européen sur
comment on construit un une vision pour
l'énergie et c'est pour ça que la France
de ce point de vue là je pense doit
tenir sa position nous avons avec
l'Alliance nucléaire montrer qu'on était
capable de créer un
conglomérat de pays qui portait cette
même vision qui était très assertif sur
l'importance de créer des signaux de
long terme l'importance de faire une
transition énergétique pragmatique
l'importance d'utiliser tous les leviers
à notre disposition pour décarboner
surtout l'importance de penser d'abord
une Europe compétitive avant de penser
des des stratégies entre nous où il y a
un gagnant et un par Nord parce que on
sera tous perdants à ce moment-là et ça
m'amène à peut-être à une forme de
conclusion
je pense que nous devons aussi
réinterroger les processus de décision
au niveau européen
on est trop lent
on est tellement lent
et et dans un monde où au contraire la
Chine les États-Unis ont montré qu'ils
étaient capables de prendre des
décisions très rapides une fashion
Redemption acte c'est un green by
américain acte point barre c'est green
enfin c'est un bail American Act d'abord
et la stratégie chinoise elle est posée
sur un mec mail making China en français
dans le texte très clair et assumé avec
la volonté de gagner 80% de part de
marché sur certaines filières
stratégiques c'est écrit noir sur blanc
il y a aucune effet de surprise c'est
public voilà donc je pense que cette
élection européenne ça doit être
l'occasion aussi de porter un agenda
beaucoup plus beaucoup moins naïf et
beaucoup plus assertif sur les sujets de
souveraineté et le faire de manière
justement c'est pour ça que moi j'aime
bien l'autonomie stratégique ouverte
c'est à dire d'assumer
que le commerce international est un
atout comme tu le disais très bien c'est
un atout mais on le porte en ayant en
étant capable de conjuguer de la
solidarité de la co-construction
ensemble mais également une volonté de
protection de nos populations comme le
font très légitimement des puissances
comme la Chine et les États-Unis
bien
Marie-Christine vous
étiez ministre de l'énergie de
l'environnement et du développement
durable et aujourd'hui quand on regarde
les liens de dépendance ils viennent
surtout du fait que on dispose que très
peu d'énergie fossiles que de très peu
de terre rares en France en Europe et
donc un quand vous étiez le ministre
vous aviez porté différents
dossiers notamment sur la thématique du
réemploi de l'économie circulaire est-ce
que demain c'est ce secteur là qui qui
nous laisse aussi des perspectives de
croissance énorme doit être au cœur de
nos préoccupations et comment on
relèvera ce défi là qui est aussi un
levier pour pour créer cette
indépendance alors avant de répondre à
votre question il y a quand même une
foule de choses à dire que je vais dire
de manière la plus synthétique possible
tout d'abord sur les constats que vous
avez fait concernant l'épuisement
démocratique alors vous n'avez pas parlé
de ça mais on y était presque quand vous
parliez je m'adresse à vous monsieur
abis c'est votre nom je crois oui donc
vous parliez en fait de l'éducation de
l'enseignement et de
l'essentiel dans tous ces apprentissages
revenir au fond aux bases se nourrir se
loger avoir suffisamment pour fonder une
famille et pour transmettre aux
générations futures la base de ce qui
fait notre humanité et ça je crois que
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut retrouver
d'urgence à travers les circuits
d'enseignement et de formation à travers
la parole publique parce que j'ai
constaté chez nos concitoyens un
épuisement démocratique il ne croit plus
non plus donc non seulement nos valeurs
vous l'avez dit tous ces chacun nos
valeurs
pratique européenne ne prennent pas
racine ne sont pas désirables dans
d'autres parties du monde donc nous ne
pouvons pas nous imposer par ce biais là
et nous devons nous en rendre compte
mais en plus nous déprimons ou en tout
cas nos populations sont elles-mêmes
déprimées par ces mêmes valeurs et
connaissent un épuisement démocratique
contre lequel il convient je trouve je
pense et j'espère qu'on est plusieurs à
penser de lutter et de lutter
efficacement alors la deuxième chose qui
me paraissait importante dans tout ce
qui a été dit c'est de rappeler quand
même que du blé ça se stocke mais de
l'électricité ça se stocke un peu moins
donc une petite pile se décharge mais un
bon stock de blé c'est les bienventé
pourra à mon avis servir un peu plus
tard dans de bonnes conditions et donc
tout le problème est là c'est que
l'énergie qui est produite doit être
consommée et que grâce aux
interconnexions terriennes
et parfois sous-marine que nous avons
avec nos voisins nous pouvons en Europe
et même au-delà assuré donc en
Grande-Bretagne assuré un
approvisionnement énergétique en
électricité puisqu'on parle de ce
vecteur là qui est valable et évidemment
pour y arriver il faut arrêter de penser
comme on l'a pensé pendant 10-15 ans
qu'on allait supprimer tous les surplus
de production d'électricité et se mettre
vraiment dans une situation de tension
comme si on pouvait déterminer à tout
moment
produire l'électricité exactement
nécessaire au besoin du moment donc on
doit refaire de la surcapacité on doit
l'exporter et le meilleur moyen de le
faire le moyen le plus je dirais
organiquement efficace et le moins cher
toutes les études le montrent c'est de
développer de grosses structures
centralisées qui produisent de
l'électricité à bas coût et qui soit
évidemment de l'électricité propre
c'est-à-dire non et maîtrise de CO2
évidemment vous connaissez la réponse
celle nucléaire donc le projet
industriel de l'Europe ça doit être les
nucléaire et j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure de aux responsables comme
maroosef covitch se tourne vers cette
filière qui me semble importantes alors
mon voisin de droite a parlé de la
Nouvelle-Zélande et de l'Australie
évidemment sont des îles donc tous les
iliens ont une pression
psychologique évidente sur l'absence
d'approvisionnement de tous les biens y
compris de l'électricité donc ils font
des efforts pour avoir des redondances
et nous on oublie évidemment Cerdon
danse c'est la même idée
ensuite on a parlé de l'armement de la
guerre sujet au combien important qui
comme l'industrialisation peut paraître
un peu sale pour des démocrates pour des
Européens aux belles valeurs mais non si
tu veux la paix prépare la guerre et
essaie de soumettre sans combattre tes
adversaires potentiels qui sont par
ailleurs dans d'autres canaux vous
l'avez dit Madame panier runachère des
des gens avec qui on peut avoir des
contrats des contrats équilibrés pour
échanger des choses et donc l'armement
et la construction européenne
à travers donc la filière militaire à
travers les achats militaires c'est un
point stratégique de l'agenda j'en
termine par l'Europe alors évidemment je
ne suis pas député européenne mais je
suis la fille politique d'un grand
député européen Gérard Depré que
certains connaissent ici et
connaissent bien ici monsieur le
Président et donc le sujet c'est quand
même le fonctionnement de l'Europe vous
l'avez également dit il est évident que
l'Europe n'est pas assez efficace
qu'elle ne parvient pas à montrer ce
dont elle est capable alors qu'elle est
riche elle est riche de culture elle est
riche sur son sol elle est riche en
technologie en intelligence et elle ne
parvient pas à montrer efficacement au
monde toute cette richesse coordonnée et
toute cette possibilité d'être un poids
essentiel par rapport aux autres
puissances qui elles travaillent de
manière un peu plus réglementaire de
manière un peu plus
hiérarchisée et caporalisante je
m'excuse mais en Chine on n'a pas le
même sens de la démocratie qu'en Europe
je pense ne pas me tromper aux
États-Unis
bon c'est le strugle forrise et donc
évidemment
en même temps c'est l'ascenseur social
mais en même temps il y a des gens qui
sont au bord du chemin donc on pense
contrairement en Europe mais il faut
aller jusqu'au bout de la logique il
faut pas être naïf vous l'avez rappelé
il faut absolument s'organiser pour être
aussi efficace que les autres tout en
gardant nos valeurs et ça commence j'y
reviens par l'enseignement et
l'éducation c'est fondamentale nos
enfants ne vont pas fondre demain il y
aura encore une terre où il fera bon
vivre c'est à nous de transmettre ce
message et d'armer nos générations pour
que la terre vive encore dans des
centaines de milliers d'années et
qu'elles soient couverte d'être humain
de plus en plus intelligents de plus en
plus solidaire et de plus en plus ouvert
sur l'autre merci
alors en décembre 2021 mode Gatel a
remis un rapport d'information sur
l'autonomie stratégique de l'Union
européenne et
et à la fin de ce rapport
il y a toute une série de d'enjeux et de
propositions je vais je vais dans Lire
quatre et je vais te laisser réagir et
me dire ce que ça ce que ça t'évoque
faire de l'Union européenne une
puissance d'innovation faire de l'Union
européenne une puissance numérique
autonome garantir un accès autonome à
l'espace et reconstruire en France et en
Europe une base industrielle est formée
les innovateurs de demain
voilà merci alors déjà bravo à Maud pour
ce rapport sur l'automobile stratégique
il a eu le bon goût de missionner dans
le cadre de son rapport donc alors entre
autres avec d'autres également donc
voilà donc je vais commenter rapidement
si tu m'autorises comme tout le monde 2
3 petites broutilles sauf que sur ce que
j'ai entendu déjà autonomie stratégique
ouverte il faut savoir que c'est quelque
chose effectivement qu'on pousse
aujourd'hui mais qui est un peu
antinomique parce que l'autonomie et
l'ouverture c'est pas toujours
exactement le même sens mais c'est une
concession que nous avons fait aux ultra
libéraux et au libéraux qui ne voulait
pas entendre parler d'autonomie
stratégique parce que c'était une remise
en cause du Marché Commun donc non non
vous inquiétez pas ça sera ouvert donc
autonomie stratégique ouverte et des
fois on dit aussi autonomise stratégique
dans le respect du Marché Commun alors
là madame vestaguer souffle un petit peu
d'autres soufflent également et donc à
l'arrivée on peut avancer pareil ça
change rien c'est juste le wording les
mots qui qui sont qui sont un petit peu
différents et
donc il y a quelque chose qu'on a oublié
dans dans cette autonomie c'est
indépendance qu'on qu'on a défendu
depuis le début de la Table Ronde c'est
dire qu'on a un allié fantastique c'est
un projet européen qui s'appelle le
pacte vert le Green Deal parce que c'est
pas seulement la décarbonation c'est
aussi l'autonomie quand vous faites une
éolienne
où que ce soit en Europe bah c'est
autant d'énergie que vous n'allez pas
importer puisqu'elle va être produite
sur le sol européen et cette dimension
on va dire
localisable de l'énergie renouvelable et
souvent un petit peu oublié et je pense
que c'est important de de leur dire
alors c'est un nouveau aussi des débats
c'est vrai que la question de
l'hydrogène l'hydrogène nous on veut
plutôt la produire en Europe on a
largement les moyens de produire en
Europe mais on a des pays amis et
voisins comme l'Allemagne par exemple
qui eux veulent absolument importer
l'hydrogène l'autre bout du monde et qui
ont fait des accords de partenariat avec
la Namibie avec avec l'Arabie Saoudite
avec le Chili pour importer demain
de l'hydrogène des carbonée de là-bas
aménager un pour méthanéen Hambourg qui
va coûter des milliards plutôt que le
produit localement une petite anecdote
si j'ai de 30 secondes les Allemands me
disaient non tu comprends il y a pas
assez de soleil dans nos pays de l'Union
européenne il faut aller produire du
hydrogène là où il y a du soleil par
exemple dans le désert
quelque chose oui il y a du soleil dans
le désert mais pour faire de l'hydrogène
il faut peut-être un petit peu d'eau
quand même ça peut être utile et ils
avaient pas pensé ah oui non non mais on
va on va désaliner l'eau de mer
imaginez 30 secondes l'électrolyse comme
ça qu'elle peut être le coup de la tonne
d'hydrogène produite et donc une
remarque plus financée par l'Europe
évidemment mais mais c'est pas si bête
que ça parce que la banque de
l'hydrogène qui est dotée d'un milliard
d'euros son but à l'origine c'était que
de financer de l'importation et nous on
s'est bagarré au Parlement européen avec
l'ensemble des collègues pour que on dit
non non j'avais encore pénal hydrogène
elle va aider les techno européennes
pour connaître la production d'hydrogène
décarbonée donc ça veut dire ça peut
être issu en France d'électricité du
réseau ou de renouvelables si on veut
mais qu'on essaie de possibilités là et
on a plutôt gagné là-dessus le texte va
arriver bientôt et je suis assez rassuré
là-dessus un élément sur la lenteur
quand même et c'est vrai que
l'Europe c'est trop long alors j'étais
rapporté sur la directive des énergies
renouvelables pour le groupe Renou on
est en 2022 on a eu les actes délégués
de la commission pour une révision de
Red de 2018 donc la fois il a fallu
quatre ans pour que la Commission ponde
un acte délégué parce qu'en fait elle
avait peur certains États membres
étaient contre etc et ils voulaient pas
aller au clash
on a en juillet 2020 lancé la stratégie
hydrogène européenne avec l'Alliance
Européenne de l'hydrogène propre juillet
2020 il a fallu attendre trois ans pour
que la Commission enfin deux ans et demi
pour être plus précis pour que la
Commission
notifie l'accord aux États membres pour
que les projets puissent commencer et en
France notamment moi j'ai tous les
industriels de l'hydrogène sur le dos
qu'est-ce qui se passe et dans le même
temps Madame vandalayen disait il faut
accélérer sur l'hydrogène on va
accélérer en accélérer et rien ne
bougeait parce qu'il est pas assez de
personnel au niveau de la DG compe qui
est en charge de ces questions là à
Bruxelles ce qui est quand même un peu
un comble et même à l'arrivée on va pas
le dire trop fort et même eu des
fonctionnaires français qui ont été mis
à disposition pour donner un petit coup
de main à l'instruction des dossiers
pour que ça avance un petit peu plus
vite enfin voilà là c'est vraiment un
exemple complet de lenteur quand
laquelle il faut lutter et c'est pour ça
que je dis aussi qu'il faut qu'on ait
des députés européens qui se bagarrent
qui s'implique parce que si on reste
tranquille pour des votes de temps en
temps machin truc
elle bougera jamais et j'aime bien aussi
citer des fois des amis des non des
ennemis extrémistes monsieur Bardella
par exemple qui nous fait des leçons
matin midi soir sur les médias français
qui se précipitent pour lire le micro et
bien il a jamais voté un seul texte qui
favorise l'industrie sur le dsadma chez
région de Noël donc toute la protection
numérique sur les données ils sont même
pas venus voter donc voilà donc il faut
aussi qu'on ait des députés qui fassent
leur boulot et pour finir sur le Tamise
stratégique et tu me parlais un petit
peu de l'accès l'espace c'est majeur
l'accès à l'espace
c'est les gars femme de demain ils sont
dans l'espace demain les les satellites
de télécommunication les constellations
de télécommunications vont nous garantir
cette autonomie européenne et on va
arrêter de dépendre des humeurs d'un
homme d'affaires comme Monsieur musk par
exemple qui un jour va donner les
satellites à l'armée ukrainienne pour
qu'il puisse connecter leur drone et
puis deux jours après ben non finalement
non avec notre constellation de
satellite européen iris 2 donc j'étais
le rapporteur pour le Parlement elle va
être opérationnelle à partir de 2024 on
va avoir vraiment quelque chose qui va
nous permettre d'être une sorte de
couteau suisse qui va sur lequel on va
pouvoir connecter de la navigation de la
télécommunication de l'observation de la
Terre et ça sera un outil très très
utile pour cette belle autonomie
stratégique
parfait
avant de laisser conclure Sébastien bise
je vais juste rebondir sur sur tout ce
qui a été dit et sur ce que tu disais au
fond on est très critique de l'Europe
mais parce qu'en fait nos attentes sont
très élevés et moi je veux saluer je
veux saluer le modèle mais je veux
saluer la vision qui a eu François
Bayrou pour justement même dans la
tempête toujours portée ces valeurs
européennes parce qu'on le voit bien
dans tout le fil de cette conversation
ce qu'on dit c'est des frustrations par
rapport à une Europe qui est finalement
notre meilleure rempart pour construire
notre souveraineté et pour porter nos
valeurs et les défendre et l'enjeu qui
est devant nous on a des élections
européennes encore une fois assez dans
quelques temps c'est d'avoir c'est de
construire un narratif qui soit un
narratif désirable sur l'Europe mais sur
lequel on montre notre notre volonté
d'aller plus loin d'aller d'aller
chercher les étoiles et d'aller les
chercher les étoiles de manière beaucoup
moins naïve et beaucoup moins arrogante
peut-être que ce qui avait été
longtemps la fin de l'histoire le
fablesse et toutes ces tout ce qui nous
ont affaibli et j'aime beaucoup cette
expression des 30 glandeseuses donc
passons au 30 travailleurs enfin mais
voilà je veux vraiment redire et saluer
l'action du MoDem parce que comme tu le
dis Jordan Bardella et cetera les
extrêmes seront toujours les premiers à
épingler et attaquer l'Europe et nous
mettre dans cette situation si on ne
critique pas l'Europe on donne le
sentiment d'être un peu des bisounours
et quand on la critique pour l'améliorer
on sert leur propos donc il faut qu'on
soit très offensif dans les mois qui
viennent sur cette question de la
souveraineté sur cette question du bon
fonctionnement de l'Europe et de
l'énorme chance qui est cette Europe
pour pour notre pays
merci beaucoup Sébastien abis
rapidement 5 points
l'Europe visionnaire
2019 il y a deux mots clés Green Deal et
géopolitique on a peut-être plus appuyé
sur le Green Deal que sur la
géopolitique mais je pense qu'il faut
maintenir le double combat et climatique
et géopolitique et peut-être que dans le
discours récentes de la présidente
grindy l'agriculture grindy l'industrie
on voit que on a des corrections qui qui
sont porteuses d'espoir pour pour les
prochaines années et encore une fois
soyons très clairs les ONG font un
travail remarquable mais doivent rester
dans une logique de critique
constructive et pas une logique de
critique terrorisante un pardon
d'utiliser cette expression
deuxième point
évidemment
il me semble que l'histoire longue nous
enseigne que la souveraineté n'a jamais
été l'AD dition de micros souveraineté
locale
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut vraiment
parler de souveraineté solidaire et à
cet égard par rapport à ces enjeux
alimentaires mondiaux puisqu'il faut
faire aussi des choix j'essaie d'être
cohérent avec ce que j'ai dit
précédemment
l'espace méditerranéen à une valeur
importante et on voit qu'on a un
paradoxe aujourd'hui c'est que dans le
développement d'une communauté politique
européenne pour essayer d'avoir des
relations qui soient particulières avec
les États qui nous entourent qui sont
candidats qui veulent nous rejoindre qui
l'ont été on a quand même sacrifié le
sud de la Méditerranée qui était
pourtant dans la politique européenne de
voisinage il y a 20 ans et donc ne
soyons pas surpris si demain le sud
global démarre au nord de l'Afrique
puisqu'on leur a expliqué qu'il ne
faisait pas partie de la communauté
politique européenne donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose je crois sur lequel on
pourrait être attentif le troisième
point c'est vraiment par rapport à
la question de passer au 30 audacieuses
il y a trois il y a trois choses moi me
semble-t-il sur des sujets transversaux
mais qui qui tournent autour des
sécurités
première
importation de bien alimentaire en
France les produits de la mer parce
qu'on ne mange pas que des produits de
la terre on achète beaucoup de saumon
notamment à l'Écosse j'en reviens je
peux le témoigner
on n'a pas développé la coiffure
alors qu'on aurait pu je sais que c'est
un sujet qui prochainement devrait
ressortir en haut de l'agenda mais on
n'a pas développé l'aquaculture parce
qu'on a fait le refus de l'industrie et
en fait on a fait un refus de
l'industrie à la campagne ou aux abords
des villes mais aussi sur les littoraux
et en bord de mer puisque en gros les
Français dans les 30 glandeuses ont
souhaité aller à la campagne et à la mer
en mode détente et loisirs donc personne
ne pouvait bosser donc ça veut dire que
l'aquaculture c'est un moyen de corriger
notre dépendance en produits bleus de la
mer et les protéines de la mer sont
largement en tête des préférences de
consommation des Français par rapport
aux insectes dans la diversité
protéinique donc un moment donné
cohérence engrais engrais nous avons des
dépendances en engrais et en même temps
il faut essayer de produire des engrais
avoir des usines en France qui
fabriquent des engrais sans engrais vous
divisez par deux les récoltes agricoles
en volume
c'est pas de l'autonomie stratégique
renforcée ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas dans les engrais aller chercher du
verdissement ce que vous disiez hein
c'est comment on maintient des sécurités
en même temps les optimisant et
enversissant tout ce qui peut l'être
l'eau le stockage de l'eau qui fait
beaucoup débats et suscite de l'émotion
les méga bassines dans certains pays on
appelle ça des barrages il y a des pays
les barrages ils sont vides donc
peut-être rappeler que les méga bassines
le terme n'était pas approprié mais
c'est pas pour des agriculteurs aller à
la piscine l'été se reposer c'est le
début de la souveraineté alimentaire
d'un pays lot donc le sujet de l'eau est
important et le stockage de l'eau c'est
un sujet qui va devenir de plus en plus
stratégique mais qui doit nécessiter un
débat citoyen parce que il y a des
financements publics est une ressource
importante mais le mobilisé aujourd'hui
en agriculture en France elle est faite
pour construire de la souveraineté
alimentaire à domicile donc vis-à-vis
des autres quatrième point proposition
ce serait bien qu'on puisse de temps en
temps rendre cohérent les stratégies
d'entreprise avec les objectifs
européens on sait que les entreprises
européennes ou françaises ont subi
depuis quelques années les pressions de
performance extra financières on a eu
les critères ESG qui se sont imposés etc
tout ça n'a pas été forcément construit
en Europe ce serait bien de temps en
temps qu'on évalue la performance
européenne des entreprises que les
entreprises européennes qui qui soient
dans la construction européenne un
critère de performance d'européanité des
entreprises puissent être établies pour
voir comment tout ça s'emboîte dans une
logique green dit les géopolitique et
puis cinquième chose je ne crois pas
l'ascenseur social je crois à l'escalier
social ça veut dire que dans un pays on
a des des droits
mais on a des devoirs et je crois que
dans ce que vous disiez sur
l'effondrement démocratique moi je crois
l'ardeur joyeuse c'est à dire ça va être
compliqué les prochaines années mais si
on embarque pas tout le monde avec une
vision d'ensemble et donc de temps en
temps et aller plus vite et en même
temps jamais se hâter pas être dans la
précipitation et l'émotion donc encore
une fois de la constance
faisait le geste de vous en vendre une
deuxième
carte
[Musique]
sa deuxième année non deux points
complémentaires parce qu'on comment oui
oui absolument
ça c'était du changement si je peux dire
si on a commencé bref non deux points
parce qu'en fait on n'a pas fait
tellement le lien et en fait on l'a fait
qu'à la fin c'est énergie et agriculture
et c'est les sujets qu'on a en partage
avec Agnès c'est y compris dans la
stratégie grinding c'est il y a un
moment il va falloir qu'on produise plus
de biomasse alors si on produit plus de
biomasse va falloir quand même qu'on se
pose des questions de comment on arrive
à produire plus de biomasse c'est la
même débats qui a eu sur l'énergie
renouvelable l'énergie au nucléaire
c'est à la fin on dit il faut faire tout
ça et avec beaucoup moins donc ça j'ai
toujours aimé le concept de on va faire
plus avec moi
mais j'ai jamais vu que ça marchait en
fait
oui
en tout cas dans ces domaines là j'y
crois assez peu donc on a besoin de
travailler sur cette question et il va y
avoir un sujet qui va être un sujet très
partition entre alimentation il y a des
débats qu'il faut qu'on pose en
conscience entre alimentation et énergie
qui a accepté le fait que ça on pourra
faire et ça on pourra pas faire
il faut qu'on classe et c'est
agriculture et forêt d'ailleurs qui vont
se qui vont se poser il me semble c'est
un élément important deuxième élément je
voulais dire c'est
il me semble qu'il y a ces crises
successives elles ont révélé les petits
égoïsmes européens de chaque État et en
fait qu'on croyait cette nuit d'accord
sur plein de choses et que sur des tas
de sujets on était parce que ne pas être
d'accord tout à fait sur les stratégies
énergétiques c'est quand même un petit
sujet devant nous quoi ne pas être
d'accord sur les stratégies commerciales
et géopolitique dans le commerce quand
même un petit sujet quand on est dans le
même espace donc on a besoin sans doute
ces crises doivent nous inciter à
revisiter
ce que nous avons commun qui n'est pas
simplement un marché unique qui avait
produit de la prospérité et les 30
glorieuses celle là
mais qui ont incité dès lors qu'on est
en crise et ça me met au dernier point
à plus savoir ce qu'on a à faire
ensemble et troisième sujet je crois
beaucoup à la question mobilité versus
agilité versus non agilité pour revenir
de nouveau dinosaures parce que c'est
pas les plus grosses suivants qui
survivent c'est les plus agiles dans ces
affaires là
et je suis frappé dans les instances
européennes de voir à quel point on est
mais d'une lenteur
je ne sais pas la qualifier en fait
tellement elle me surprend et pourtant
j'ai quand même un petit peu de derrière
boutique si je peux dire politique et je
vois à peu près comment tout ça
fonctionne mais quand sur un sujet par
exemple sur la question de la jachère on
vient nous dire la réponse n'est pas on
est contre on est pour mais c'est trop
compliqué ça va être trop long
le jour où on aura la guerre à la porte
parce qu'elle est à la porte là mais ça
va passer la porte on dirait
excusez-nous on a un processus
décisionnel dont on pourra se reparler
dans six mois ou un an or je pense que
l'Europe a capacité à faire vite elle
l'a fait dans certains cas covid elle
l'a fait
énergie elle l'a fait et donc il faut
qu'on tire exemple de ce qu'on a fait de
d'agilité et que dans notre process de
décision on fasse d'une Europe agile
parce que dans ce monde là si on n'est
pas capable d'avoir des réactions de
l'ordre de la semaine ou du mois et
qu'il faut des années à ce moment là je
sais comment ça finira pas bien à mon
avis merci beaucoup
pardon pour nourrir le débat puisque
vous allez l'achever
un petit débat avec ce que Marc vient de
dire qui paraît du bon sens
et dont je suis pas persuadé moi que ça
soit vrai il dit j'entends dire depuis
la plupart du temps 99% du temps il dit
des choses intelligentes et juste
c'est même pour ça qu'il est là mais
quand il dit reprenons ce que en fait
tout le monde pensait dire
on peut pas faire plus avec moi moi je
voudrais lui donner un exemple dans son
champ sans jeu de mots
pour montrer qu'on peut faire beaucoup
plus
avec moi
avant la guerre alors comme vous savez
le Béarn c'est le plus beau pays du
monde les Pyrénées c'est sublimes et au
pied des Pyrénées il y a une plaine qui
est
siliconeuse comme on dit chez vous
c'est-à-dire aussi fertile que la plaine
du pot
de peau et du pot
dans ce pays là terre à maïs par
excellence
avant la guerre le rendement était de 15
quintaux hectares
et puis un jour on a eu l'idée des gens
ont eu l'idée entre chez nous et l'Ayo
aux États-Unis
d'hybrider le maïs
c'est à dire de croiser les lignées de
maïs qui est pas très facile parce que
le Maïs est une plante hermaphrodite à
la fois mâle et femelle il fallait donc
couper la partie mâle du maïs pour que
la partie femelle
reçoivent des gamètes qui permettaient
d'hybrider le maïs
on est passé dès l'instant qu'on a fait
ça sans ajouter un kilo d'engrais on est
passé de 15 quintaux hectares à 70
quintaux hectares en une seule année et
donc moi je plaide
auprès du ministre de l'Agriculture
auprès de toutes les instances qui sont
là pour qu'on se dise que c'est possible
qu'on arrive à relever des défis qui
paraissaient impossible à affronter et
que simplement la créativité humaine
l'intelligence humaine notre capacité
scientifique et technique et
n'a pas les limites qu'on croit et que y
croire c'est aussi une manière d'ouvrir
des portes sur l'avenir qui autrement
apparaissent définitivement fermé
merci
ça y est la controverse n'est
bien il est temps pour moi de conclure
cette table ronde je tiens vraiment
remercier nos intervenants pour ces pour
ces échanges alors les constats sont
faits certains se contentent de faire
des constats et ce qui me rassure à la
fin de cette table ronde et j'en avais
aucun doute c'est que nous on agit on
agit vite on agit fort et on continuera
de le faire je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]